JOHN BRENNAN WORKS FOR MSNBC,
NOT CNN.
A REALLY SAD DAY FOR THE COUNTR
COUNTRY, THE PRESIDENT LOOKING
VERY SAD AND SOMBER AT THE
WHITE HOUSE, NOW HE'S GOT A BIG
RALLY TONIGHT, TURN OUT THE BASE
FOR THE MIDTERMS.
A TOUGH SITUATION FOR THE
COUNTRY AND FOR THE PRESIDENT
AND BOTH POLITICAL PARTIES.
>> Dana: >> ONE OF THE TI
>> Dana: >> ONE OF THE TG
>> Dana: >> ONE OF THE TS
>> Dana: >> ONE OF THE TH
>> Dana: >> ONE OF THE TE
>> Dana: >> ONE OF THE TS
>> Dana: >> ONE OF THE TI
>> Dana: >> ONE OF THE T,
>> Dana: >> ONE OF THE TM
>> Dana: >> ONE OF THE TY
NUMBER ONE RESPONSIBILITY IS THE
PEOPLE.
I ALSO THINK, THIS IS A BIG
DEAL.
HE HAD JUST HAD A BRIEFING FROM
THE U.S. SECRET SERVICE,
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, FBI, AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY.
THEY ARE COORDINATING WITH THE
ALCOHOL, TOBACCO, AND FIREARMS,
AND THE NYPD, WASHINGTON, D.C.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT THEY
TRAIN FOR, THEY PLANNED FOR, IT
IS UNFORTUNATE.
THE GOOD NEWS FOR AMERICA IS
THAT THE U.S. SECRET SERVICE, A
VERY GOOD INVESTIGATORS.
THEY HAVE GREAT LEADS, THE
ABILITY TO TRACK THIS DOWN,
PLUS, THANKFULLY, BECAUSE NONE
OF THESE DENTAL RANGES, THEY
HAVE THE EVIDENCE TO LOOK
THROUGH, FIND A FINGERPRINT,
CROSS-CHECK WITH SOCIAL MEDIA
POSTS.
I'M NOT TRYING TO DOWNPLAY IT.
IT'S EXTREMELY SERIOUS, THERE
COULD BE MORE OUT THERE, BUT THE
FULL WEIGHT OF OUR INVESTIGATIVE
CAPABILITIES MAKES IT ALL THE
MORE LIKELY THAT THIS WILL BE
CAUGHT SOONER THAN LATER.
>> Jesse: HOPEFULLY AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THE
TARGETS HERE, ALL HIGH PROFILE,
VERY HARSH CRITICS OF THIS
PRESIDENT, IT JUST A SERIES OF
MALE BOMBINGS TO THESE
INDIVIDUALS, DOES THIS MAKE ANY
SENSE TO YOU?
>> Greg: YOU CAN DRAW A NUMBER
OF CONCLUSIONS.
YOU CAN SAY, WELL, THIS IS
SOMEBODY THAT DOESN'T MAKE THESE
PEOPLE, BUT I WOULD SAY THIS IS
NOT A NORMAL ACT, SO DON'T ACT
LIKE IT'S A NORMAL ACT BY A
NORMAL PERSON TRIGGERED BY
RHETORIC.
IT IS AN ACT OF TERROR BY,
LIKELY, A DERANGED PERPETRATOR
OR A GROUP.
BUT WHEN I LOOK AT STUFF LIKE
THAT, IT LOOKS ALMOST ALWAYS
LIKE IT IS A SINGLE PERSON.
BUT I AM A WEIGHT-AND-C GUY.
AT TIMES LIKE THIS
, YOU SHOULD HAVE LESS
SPECULATION, NOT MY SPECULATION.
THE PROBLEM IS, YOU ARE REQUIRED
TO FILL TIME AND SPECULATE, BUT
I REALIZE WHEN IT COMES TO MASS
SHOOTINGS AND SUSPICIOUS
PACKAGES AND CERTAIN EVENTS, THE
FIRST CONCLUSION IS OFTEN -- THE
FIRST CONCLUSION ON TWITTER IS
NEVER THE RIGHT ONE.
THE GUY THAT COMES OUT FIRST
USUALLY ENDS UP LOOKING LIKE AN
IDIOT.
YOU NEED LESS SPECULATION,
THAT'S BETTER.
I WANT TO SAY THIS IS AN
ILLUSTRATION, HOW EASY IT IS TO
DISRUPT A FREE SOCIETY WITH FEAR
AND PANIC.
ONE PERSON OR A HANDFUL OF
PEOPLE CAN HAVE AN IMPACT OF
MILLIONS WITH BOXES, PIPES, AND
POSTAGE.
I THINK THE UPSIDE OF THIS IS
THAT IT IS SO SHOCKING BECAUSE
IT'S RARE, AND WE HAVE TO REMIND
OURSELVES IT SHOCKS US, BECAUSE
BACK IN THE 1970s, THIS WASN'T
RARE.
THIS WAS A COMMON PROBLEM.
THEY WERE ACTUAL TERROR GROUPS,
DOMESTIC TERROR GROUPS, MORE
THAN A HANDFUL OF THEM, WHO WERE
SETTING BOMBS, PIPE BOMBS,
TRYING TO KILL POLICE OFFICERS,
THIS WAS A REGULAR THING IN THE
EARLY '70s, MITT '70s.
SO THIS IS A RARE, DISGUSTING
EVENTS.
IT IS AN ACT OF TERROR.
BUT TO GO AND TRY TO SPECULATE
ON ANYTHING WITHOUT FIRST HAVING
AN ARREST OR SUSPECT, I WOULD
STAY AWAY FROM IT.
>> Jesse: I THINK RECENTLY
TRUMP FAMILY MEMBERS RECEIVED
WHITE POWDER IN THE MAIL, AND
TRUMP CABINET MEMBERS RECEIVED
RICIN, BUT THIS TAKES IT TO A
WHOLE 'NOTHER LEVEL WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE LEVEL OF DEMOCRATIC
OFFICEHOLDERS, FORMER PRESIDENT
PRESIDENTS, FORMER
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S, AND GEORGE
SOROS IS VERY, VERY INFLUENTIAL
PERSON IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
IN TERMS OF FUND-RAISING AND
THINGS LIKE THAT.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE ABOUT TODAY'S
EVENT?
>> Juan: WHEN I LISTEN TO YOU
GUYS TALK ABOUT THE RALLY
TONIGHT AND HOW THE PRESIDENT
WOULD HAVE TO WALK A TIGHTROPE,
WHAT STRIKES ME IS THAT HIS
RHETORIC IS QUITE INCENDIARY AT
THESE EVENTS.
I DON'T THINK THIS IS
REPRESENTATIVE OF HIS SUPPORTERS
ANYWAY, BUT I DO THINK THERE ARE
PEOPLE OUT THERE WHO HEAR HIM
VERY CLEARLY WHEN HE SAYS, OH,
THOSE DEMOCRATS, LOCK UP
HILLARY CLINTON, BARACK OBAMA,
HE IS NOT REALLY AN AMERICAN.
THESE PEOPLE WANT TO DO WITH
I.C.E., THEY DON'T WANT BORDERS.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO WANT TO
TURN AMERICA INTO IT -- THE
RHETORIC.
AND HE IS THE ONE WHO ALWAYS
SAID, GO AHEAD AND PUNCH THEM.
I'LL PAY YOUR LEGAL BILLS.
THE BIG PROBLEM AROUND HERE IS
THAT WE DON'T WANT TO HURT
ANYONE ANYMORE.
THAT KIND OF RHETORIC, I DON'T
CARE IF YOU ARE REPUBLICAN ARE
DEMOCRAT, THAT DOESN'T CITE
VIOLENCE.
A NUMBER PEOPLE ON THE LEFT, THE
INSTINCT, AND I THINK IT'S A
MISTAKE, WOULD BE TO JUMP AND
SAY, I KNOW EXACTLY THE FORCE OF
THIS.
>> Jesse: YOU JUST DID.
YOU JUST SAID IT'S FREDERICK.
>> Juan: I THINK YOU AND DANA
BOTH SPOKE TO THIS.
HE USES FEAR TO STIR HIS FACE.
>> Jesse: YOU ARE IMPLYING
THAT BECAUSE THIS?
>> Juan: I AM IMPLYING THAT IS
THE SOCIETY WE LIVE IN TODAY.
I THINK IT IS WHEN THE PANTS ARE
POLITICAL OPPONENTS AS PEOPLE
WHO ARE NOT AMERICANS, NOT
PATRIOTS, NOT WORTHY, AND
THEN IT INVITES THE KIND OF LOAN
ACTOR, SOMEONE WHO MAY DERANGED,
TO PARTICIPATE IN THIS.
>> Jesse: IS THERE A LINE
BETWEEN THIS?
>> Emily: WITH ALL DUE RESPECT
TO JUAN, IT IS IRRESPONSIBLE TO
MAKE THAT ASSUMPTION, THAT
TITHER THAT RHETORIC CAUSES IT.
RECENTLY WE HAD A FORMER
DEMOCRATIC STAFFER THAT WAS
CHARGED WITH MULTIPLE FELONIES
FOR DOUSING THREE CENTERS.
YOU CAN'T ISOLATE NOT ONLY --
THAT BRINGS ME TO MY NEXT POINT,
WE SHOULDN'T ISOLATE THIS, OR
SHOULD WE SHOULD INCLUDE A
LARGER SPECTRUM OF WHAT THIS ACT
MEANS.
SO THERE WAS AN EXPLOSIVE
DEVICE.
THERE WAS ALSO POWDER, AS HE
POINTED OUT.
THOSE ARE TRICK WITH DIFFERENT
THINGS.
WHEN I GOT MY DEATH THREAT IS A
FEDERAL ACTING DIRECTOR, I WAS
ABLE TO CALL IN FEDERAL SERVICE
SERVICES, OPD, THEY WERE ACTIVE
DOORSTEP WITHIN 30 MINUTES.
MY POINT IS, THE
THERE IS A WHOLE SPECTRUM OF
THEM, AND THEY TREAT EVERY
THREAT.
THE WORD "CREDIBLE THREAT,"
THAT'S A MISNOMER.
EVERY THREAT IS CREDIBLE.
NOTHING IS ISOLATED OR IGNORED,
AND THAT SPEAKS TO INTEGRITY OF
THE SECRET SERVICE AND FBI.